ALI AFSHAR: And hello, everyone,
and welcome to the
Google Drive SDK
question time.
I'm Ali, and with
me today is--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Alain.
Nice to meet you.
ALI AFSHAR: So we're going
to go through some of the
questions we've been asked.
And Alain, our expert here, is
going to give us some answers.
If you don't know, we
answer technical
questions on Stack Overflow.
So if you have any questions,
please ask them there, and
they will be dealt
with immediately.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Make sure
to tag them with the tag
Google-Drive-SDK, and it should
appear on our Stack
Overflow stream.
ALI AFSHAR: So let's
get started.
How can FILESTREAM serve matrix
be API queried from
Google Drive?
Let's say I push a video to
Google Drive, I share the
video link with various users.
Is there a way to obtain the
number of bytes served, and by
whom, or of some unique ID?
Alain?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, this
information is not yet
available for the API.
But it's kind of a good
future request.
Like, we might consider it.
Actually, it's the first time
we've had this future request.
But right now, as a work-around
the data has to be
served through either JavaScript
client application
or server application.
So the matrix can be stored in
the application instead.
Because this information
is not yet available.
ALI AFSHAR: I think it would be
a useful feature, actually.
But unfortunately, you can't
do that directly.
And so you're talking about
serving files using
JavaScript, or however, using
a server application.
Is that the only way you
can download files?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Actually, no.
Since last week, we introduced
the web content link which is
a link you can copy and paste
into a web browser.
If a file is shared with the
public, the browser will
simply download the
file's content.
And if the file's private,
it will use cookie
authentications to make sure
of their current user has
access to the file's content.
And then download the file,
if this is the case.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, so just to get
that clear, your application
can give someone a URL, and they
can download that URL if
they're already authorized into
their Google services.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
ALI AFSHAR: Wow, that's
pretty cool.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Even if
you're serving a web page, for
instance, you can put an image
web content link as the src
attribute of an image
tag, and it will be
served on the web browser.
ALI AFSHAR: Great.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Regarding
the matrix for a file's
content, [INAUDIBLE]
there are many things
to consider.
Like should the matrix be
shared amongst different
applications?
Should it be global to a user,
to the rest of the world?
What do you think?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, I think those
are important things,
and we'd have to really
think about them.
If the file is shared with you,
should you be able to
access the download information
on that?
Or should it just be for the
owner of the file, or the
creator of the file?
Both the application
or the user?
So I think those are things that
we'd have to think about.
But yes, thank you, we'll
take that future
request away with us.
So on to the next question.
I read question earlier.
Google Apps domains
Drive Migrator.
Is it possible to build cross
domain Drive Migrator?
The Docs List API was great, but
it doesn't support files.
I should say that's wrong
actually, it does support
files and did support files.
But I guess someone's looking
to migrate all of the files
from one domain over
to another domain.
How would you go about
doing that, Alain?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Migrating
of files is pretty easy.
You can simply download the
content and re-upload to the
new domain.
But I think the tricky part he's
mentioning is the ECHO.
How to transfer the ECHO from
one domain to the new one.
ALI AFSHAR: So can you tell
us what you mean by ECHO?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
The permissions.
As many of you already know,
Google Drive lets you share a
file with different users.
That can be a specific user, a
group, a domain, or the rest
of the world.
And every file has a list of
permissions which can be read
permissions, so the user has
read-only access to a file,
write permission, a user can
read and write on the file, or
commenting permission, so the
user can read the file and
comment on the file.
ALI AFSHAR: Right,
so how would you
get about doing that?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well
there's the tricky
part with Drive API.
Because the permission feed
doesn't return the email
address anymore.
You only get the display name
as a variable on Google+, or
using the user profile
information.
So the way to do it would be
to try to match the user ID
return by the permission--
by the Drive API on permissions
feed, and match it
with the new user's ID.
Otherwise, I don't see
any work-around.
ALI AFSHAR: So they're
a bit stuck there,
actually for that case.
As Alain says, rightly, you
could create the users, or the
users could already exist in the
target domain, the domain
you're going to be saving to.
You would go through, find
them, and match the IDs.
And then you would do that.
[INAUDIBLE].
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: It might
even require us using much
more APIs, such as some of the
domain admin's APIs, to
retrieve a user's data, such as
their email address and the
full name, their ID.
And do the same on the new
domain and store both data,
and try to do a match.
ALI AFSHAR: So that's what
you would do, then.
You would create the map
yourself and then map the
files like that.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, great.
All right, thank you, Alain.
How do I get notification when
a user deletes a file?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, push
notifications is a major
future request.
It's been asked for years.
It's not yet available.
Hopefully, we'll be able
to provide these to our
developers.
In the meantime, the only way to
get change notification is
to pull the Drive API.
Pulling the list of files can
require lots of resource,
because you get lots of data,
and have to process
[? change ?] over the updated
time and know if the file has
changed or not.
So that's why the Drive API
provides a change feed, but
only returns changes that
occurred after a
specific change ID.
And when a user [INAUDIBLE] a
file, this information is
provided for the changes feed.
ALI AFSHAR: So can you just
say how that would look?
If the file's been deleted, is
there information about the
file in the changes feed?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
You get a change item with the
file ID, and a deleted
attribute, which is set
to true, if the
file has been deleted.
ALI AFSHAR: And in this changes
feed, how would you
differentiate that entry from
an entry where a file has
simply be modified?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, the
deleted attribute won't be
provided on the change item, and
the file's metadata would
be included instead.
ALI AFSHAR: So why don't
we include the file
metadata for a delete?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Because this
is simply because a file
has been deleted so we don't
have this information anymore.
ALI AFSHAR: Sorry, I asked you
a trick question there.
ALI AFSHAR: No worries.
He's used it.
Google Drive API Python.
ALI AFSHAR: [INAUDIBLE]
question is there?
In order to write a desktop
Python app using Google Drive
[INAUDIBLE]
Twisted with Drive SDK, which
makes the thing complicated
and difficult to find
useful stuffs.
Can anyone give some
useful information?
Well, have you used Twisted?
I'm a long time user
of Twisted.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I've
never tried it.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, so for those of
yo that don't know Twisted
is an asynchronous
Python networking
library stroke framework.
I'd like to think of it
more as a library.
What it does is it runs a
reactor in the background
that's a long running process
that schedules various network
activities, and other
things that can be
running for a long time.
So you can integrate user
interface-- that's another
thing that runs for
a long time--
into that.
Now, Twisted itself asks you
to write code in a special
way, and it has its
own HTTP client.
And unfortunately, our client
library isn't directly
compatible with that.
So there are other tricks
around that.
And what you essentially have to
do is, every time you want
to make an API request,
you have to
delegate that to a thread.
And it's dedicated to a
thread and it runs.
And when it's finished, it
calls back the response.
Now, the callback mechanism
in Twisted uses
something called deferreds.
Which is an object that returns
immediately, but later
has a call back, or in an error
case-- an errback, they
call it-- that is called.
So what you have to do there is
you have to defer each API
call to a thread and wait
for the response.
And that's if you're
using Twisted.
Now, I've actually got some
sample code because I use
Twisted, and I have used
it with the Drive API.
So I'll make sure I get some
sample code to you, Robin W.
Thanks for asking
that question.
If you haven't tried Twisted,
and you're a fan of Python,
and you're writing any network
application, or any demon kind
of application, it's
something that you
really should consider.
Some people don't like it, but I
think it's really fantastic.
Excellent integration, very well
tested, and as far as I
can tell, some of the best
Python developers in the world
are people who work
on this library.
So Twisted is great.
Next question.
Query for a list of files and
folders in the root directory.
I would like to get a list of
files and folders in the root
directory without having to sort
through all the files.
Is there a query that
would do this?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Nice.
Good question.
Well actually you have queue
query parameter, which
supports a simple language
that you can use.
And to query files that are in
the root directory, you can
send a request to the
file's [INAUDIBLE]
end-point, specifying the query
parameter, Q equals root
in parents.
Root is an alias to specify that
you want files that are
in the root directory.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, so
[INAUDIBLE].
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes,
that's correct.
ALI AFSHAR: One thing I just
want to clear up, are there
folders in the root directory?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: You can
specify, as well, [? MIME ?]
type in the query parameter.
And the queue query
[INAUDIBLE]
search parameters such
as not, and--
and that's it.
ALI AFSHAR: So what you're
saying is that you can join
these search clauses, and you
can refine you're query?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
ALI AFSHAR: So other interesting
thing you
mentioned was the alias root.
So the root folder is just a
folder like any other folder
in Drive, is that right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
That's correct.
ALI AFSHAR: So what
is this root?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: This is
required because the root ID--
the root for the ID can
be different from
among each of the users.
That's why you have an
alias, to simply
refer to the root folder.
ALI AFSHAR: Ok, so that makes
that nice and easy.
That's one of the cases the
wasn't particularly easy with
the Documents List API, but
now it's made much easier.
So great.
Here's a question
with some code.
Google Drive API download
file Get IO error.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
I think I've seen
this question earlier.
And it was because of a typo
on the documentation which
will get fixed today,
hopefully.
Yes.
The documentation had
been written maybe
three months ago.
And the client library changed
between now and then.
So we need to update our
documentation to reflect that.
ALI AFSHAR: So instead of
calling Get IO, which is just
a method on the service, the
IO is now an instance,
instance attribute.
OK, great.
So typo.
If you find something wrong with
our documentation please
let us know.
We're keen to have it perfect
and up to date at all times.
So this is a great
example of that.
ASP.NET?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Oh, sorry,
I'm not familiar with this.
You want to give it a shot?
ALI AFSHAR: Well let's
have a read.
Why not?
It will be a challenge for us.
External ASP.NET MVC application
accessing files on
Google Drive.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, I
believe the doctor edit sample
application we have in
.NET is using MVC.
Unfortunately it's in C#.
There might be an easy way to
understand C# and transform it
into ASP.NET but we're
not expert in that.
ALI AFSHAR: So we're no experts,
but as far as I know,
ASP.NET you can write
it in C#.
You can write it in any
of the languages.
Is that right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well,
.NET's the framework.
ASP is only a different
language.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
Unfortunately, we're
a bit clueless.
Luckily our colleague,
Claudio, has
answered this question.
And he's saying that
it can be done.
And we have an example
application that uses the
ASP.NET MVC framework.
So go and have a look at that.
It's a complete end-to-end
sample that shows you how to
open files from the Drive UI,
read files from Drive API,
save files back to Drive.
A few other little bits
and pieces, how to get
authorization, of course,
information about the user,
and customization
in that regard.
So that's a good one.
Go ahead and check that out
on our documentation page.
Save files from Android app to
Google Drive without using
HTTP request.
I saw this one earlier.
I couldn't quite work
out what it was.
I want to save files
from my Android
application to Google Drive.
But I don't want to use
HTTPS requests.
I want to put my files in Google
Drive even if the user
is offline like the
local drive.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Oh, I see.
I guess what they're requesting
is a way for the
Android Drive App to receive
intent to save data.
Unfortunately, this is not yet
available, but quite a good
future request.
We can pass that on to the
Android Drive App team.
In the meantime, the only way
to save data on Drive, on
Android, or any other platform,
is to use the API.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah,
that's right.
One work-around could be if
you can find out where the
local copies of the Drive
files are being saved.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
But I'm not even sure if you
know where, you'd be
able to save data.
You might not have permission
to write on
the local data store.
ALI AFSHAR: Precisely.
Where this would work is
in the desktop clients
on Windows and Mac.
You could just ask the user
where the drive directory is
and then copy files into that.
Again, the permissions
might be wrong.
They might not be permitted.
But that would work as
a work-around there.
Unfortunately, there are no
APIs to interact with the
Drive client on that regards.
So for saving files, or
where the files are.
So that could be somewhere
where we'd look
to imporove, I think.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes, that can
be better for developers,
as they won't have to deal with
offline and any other
network issues on Android.
ALI AFSHAR: Precisely.
Google Drive root folder,
file not found error.
I had written a program that
creates a file object which
defaults gets created in
the root folder if
no parent is specified.
Then, given the ID of the file's
parent, it retrieves
the root folder.
For some reason, this
no longer works.
Instead of returning the root
folder, I get "File not
found." So this is the thing.
That's some Ruby code.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So
Steve answered.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah,
Now, I think the best thing to
do is instead of trying to
find the root folder in that
way, is to find the root
folder just by asking
for the root folder.
Now, you could do that by
going to googleapis.com,
Drive, v2, files, and then
root as the file ID.
And in the same way that the
root alias works the queries,
it also works to look up
files and fetch them.
So that's by far the quickest
and easiest way to do that.
The other way of finding the ID
of the root folder, can you
tell us how to do that?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Sure.
It's from the about resource.
The Drive API provides an about
end-point which returns
information about the current
user, just as quota, how much
could quota is left, how much
quota has been used.
And among that, the
root folder ID.
ALI AFSHAR: So that's in the
about feed, but we recommend
you just use the root alias.
Would you say that?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: It's
more convenient.
And you get more metadata by
doing a query to the root
metadata and resource.
ALI AFSHAR: So great.
Resize an image retrieved from
Google Drive using the API.
So I think this will be our
last question for today.
I'm using the following
Python code to get a
file from Google Drive.
They're calling a Get
request on a file
passing in a file ID.
How would I go about resizing
this file if it is an image?
I've tried the following,
resized image equals images
dot resize, and then that.
But I get the following error,
"Not image error."
So let's role that back a second
and say, I guess this
is a Python on App Engine, using
the Images service to
resize a file.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Probably.
ALI AFSHAR: Is that right?
Now, the problem that's happened
here is that being
passed in is the download
URL of the file.
Which I don't think that's
going to work.
I think you need to pass in the
binary data of the file.
Is that right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I think so.
And even if that could work,
it won't work in their use
case, because the download URL
requires an authorization
header, which needs to be
provided with a get request.
ALI AFSHAR: So what would
you recommend?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, I would
recommend downloading
the file's data using the
download URL, and provide the
authorization header,
as documented in
our reference guide.
And get this data and
pass it to the
image API and App Engine.
ALI AFSHAR: Now, I'm not
exactly sure, but I'm
imagining the Images service
could work on a file that's in
the Blobstore?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Probably.
ALI AFSHAR: So if it can--
and sorry, we're not App Engine
specific experts here--
but if it can, then you could
just save it directly into the
Blobstore, and then call the
resize on the Blobstore.
But otherwise, you could just
use the binary bits, and then
that would work.
So that I should solve that.
Unfortunately it's not going
to work, what's happening
here, because you just passing
a string, which is the URL,
and that's why it's
not image error.
OK, so thank you very much.
That's our questions
for today.
We'll be back again
on Thursday.
Ask your questions, and
we look forward
to speaking to you.
So bye from Ali.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Bye from Alain.